los sindicatos contaban con una gran
participación y no quedaron
decepcionados en toda Francia decenas de
miles de personas salieron a las calles
unidas en su oposición a la reforma de
las pensiones del gobierno de Emanuel
mccall que busca aumentar la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años una cuarta
parte de los pobres mueren a los 62 años
y Quieren poner la edad de jubilación a
los 65 eso no tiene sentido como jóvenes
también seremos los primeros en sentir
el impacto Si la gente permanece más
tiempo en sus puestos de trabajo Eso
significa más desempleo para nosotros
en este momento los beneficios de las
grandes empresas están aumentando porque
siempre el trabajador el que tiene que
pagar cuando hay otras opciones de
financiación los sindicatos propusieron
muchas soluciones al gobierno pero
ninguna fue aceptada siempre somos
nosotros los que tenemos que pagar
mientras otros se llenan los bolsillos
los
afirman que 400.000 personas se
manifestaron en París y más de un millón
en el resto del país una movilización
masiva que según ellos refleja la
oposición generalizada a la Reforma por
primera vez en más de una década todos
los sindicatos franceses fueron Unidos
hoy se ha dado un verdadero primera
aviso si es suficiente estupendo si no
es suficiente continuaremos
esta noche la pelota estará del lado del
gobierno pero probablemente habrá un
segundo paso
el presidente ha afirmado desde España
su determinación de seguir adelante con
la reforma